okay four people joining our live stream
we are in the late stages of finishing
documentation and other things for our
new synthetic geometry capabilities for
version 12 of mileage so the first thing
we were looking at is geometric scene
and I think we need to look at this
documentation page we need to see all
the things it does boy why are we saying
it that way I mean if it's represent I
think this is not a great accessory
many examples or do you have examples
here but you got to explain this
business about how this generates a
scene that has literal ABCs in it right
okay well I don't know what what is this
thing this thing like an example showing
the input form well yeah I mean that
particular thing now if I say input form
of that it will have literalized this
ABC so what I would do here is to say
the first example here I would say
geometric scene of oops um a arrow you
know one zero B arrow I don't know tell
me a triangle um actually I would like
to say zero zero B arrow
[Music]
okay and now I don't know why that
braces that as that brace needed yes it
is sorry yeah the hypotheses are is in
this form okay so there okay so this
would be you know represent a geometric
scene with explicit coordinates for
points okay um and now I think what we
want to say would be something like okay
here we'll say a geometric seen a
symbolic geometric seen this this
discard this this is here is a symbolic
this is a symbolic geometric scene um
actually it'd be nice to put some
constraint in there I don't know in the
representing a triangle with interior
angle what's the angle
so say planar angle of list ABC ya say
something yeah I already explained our
angle we just also polygon angle equals
equal it's 130 degrees okay let's say
equals equals 30 degrees why not
actually let's do it the other way
around
okay so okay a geometric this this
represents a symbolic geometric seen
this of a triangle with angle thirty
degrees okay random instance fills in
explicit well okay no why don't we say
this gives this cut this represents a
symbolic geometric scene containing a
triangle
explicit coordinates for the points can
we say finds explicit coordinates for
the points I wouldn't because that's not
what we're talking about here right what
we're talking about here is geometric
seen right and also it returns the
geometric scene itself with the
coordinates filled in so yes Stevens
right I don't know whether we want to do
the input form you should do the input
form further down um is there anything
you can do now to sort of show that it
is okay let's say conclusions there or
something can we do that there are no
conclusions for that okay so you do
hypotheses well let's let's do points
yeah I don't think that there's a bug
for in this version it's been oh wait
yeah there's a bug in this version where
points just returns to all the variables
it's been what's wrong with this I mean
this is this looks more or less right
here you could also has the empty list
no I understand that okay fills in
explicit this finds the finds the rule
rules giving this gets the rules
corresponding to the points gets the
rules giving coordinates for the points
okay let's go back up here I mean this
may not be perfect but this is my
attempt here um okay so let's go back up
to the top okay
represents a two geometric scene with
points involving points P involving
points P sub I and no geometric scene
Laura I'm goats at defined by hypotheses
in terms of the points how about that in
terms of the points P sub I okay so now
what's this numerical quantities what
does that mean right there are scalars
I'm not necessarily sure he should play
numerical there because they're still
symbolic I would private to scalar
values yeah represents a scene whose
height
is depend depend on the scale of values
quesa by okay represents okay wait a
minute wait a minute
represents a class of two geometric
scenes is that right here because this
says a particular instance so if there
are rules for everything then it's it
should be a particular instance no no I
understand that but what do we say about
this one if this isn't an instance what
is this one of this I don't think it is
actually I think we should change the
way this is said here it's more abstract
vs. complete okay represents are two
defined by in terms of the UM in terms
of the symbolic points P sub I you want
to say represents an abstract to the
geometric scene and then now it's not a
bad idea
I've defined by the hypothesis I mean
hypotheses the weird term when you've
got a triangle sitting there it's the
existence that you postulate because I'm
covering nice philosophical recovery
Michael no because the geometric scene
might be empty
it might not exist represents an
abstract to the geometric scene
time by involving the symbolic points
and defined by the hypotheses that seem
reasonable involving Thompson top sports
crude so it's pretty clear what you can
put in hit okay defined by the
hypotheses okay represents a scene which
I posses depend on the scalar and the
symbolic scalar values case by ok
represents a specific instance of the
geometry of a geometrics of the of the
geometrics specific instance of a
geometric scene with particular
coordinates for each point that
reasonable many flavors of meanings okay
with definite coordinates with explicit
coordinate or something okay represents
multiple specific instances of a scene
represents a collection of specific
instances
presents a scene for which from which
some conclude 'fl from which the
conclusions conser by have been derived
or can be derived no because you can put
any drunk in if true or not okay well so
what's the point of this one well it's
the the fine geometric conjectures code
makes conjectures though its are
probably true but maybe not true in
general and but when that returns a
value it returns to geometric scene with
the conjectures in that last argument
well the user might want to put
something that seemed sensible to the
use of manually ok represents the scene
together with some conclusions about it
ok ok ok no this isn't right it's not a
diagram right it really isn't a diagram
it's displayed what we want to say a
geometric scene object with I think what
you're writing is going further than
geometric scene instance is displayed in
standard well no too far just to see
legs yeah a geometric
instance is displayed in standard form
in traditional form as a graphical image
to start with that I don't believe in
that one let's let's try writing it
again
I mean somewhat somewhat similar okay a
geometric scene object with explicit
values for the coordinates of points but
it's the explicit values for all points
and scalars for explicit court with
explicit coordinates and values is
displayed as a graphical diagram we can
say is normally displayed as a graphical
diagram how do you feel about that I
think I think your use of the voir dire
comm is a little bit different than the
use of the voir dire comb in our
original first one because we don't use
to exceed about dial com2 for our
classics I know but this is this I call
a diagram has got these weird blue
points and things and it's got all kinds
of angle markers and so on that's why
I'm George's diagram I mean this is a
new class of graphic it's a diagram
right and I mean for example we should
make sure that in the key words here
that we have the word diagram I think
should be in there construction Euclid
um you know certainly geometric
construction should be in there um
anyway ok alright so let's keep going
down here
includes that includes specific that
includes explicit no no way this better
work that all of them have to be filled
in yeah it's about to say you should say
something about all okay
points and scalars explicit coordinates
for all points and explicit values for
all scalars
it's normally displayed as a graphical
diagram okay
now
we got to say what can be in the
hypotheses and my opinion
um I think this comes much lower first
we have to say
the hypotheses herbs hypotheses in the
scene
you
can contain
well we're gonna basically give this big
long list right yeah basically
objects in the nations okay can ok the
hypothesis in the scene can contain
specifications for objects indicating
that those objects can exist indicating
that those objects exist as well as
relations and assertions about
measurements on those objects is that
correct necessarily okay assertions okay
but I pathi season and the scene can
contain specifications or objects well
can assert that certain objects exist as
well as give relations and assertions
about those objects okay um
the following primitives foreign
primitives can be used to indicate that
particular objects exist now it's this
thing here basically right
um I think explicitly bringing up this
existence thing is kind of esoteric why
it's very confusing otherwise everything
else is a as us as a statement right now
that I mean in you know the if the the
existence of say a simple polygon you
know in the context of all these other
hypotheses is not trivial but just why
isn't regular polygons in that list the
beginning there why doesn't that contain
regular polygons it said it's supported
okay I think this is in the wrong order
okay I think it's in way the wrong order
this thing here I mean I would I would
go from why isn't this going from it's
an alphabetical order oh for goodness
sake that's wrong that's crazy wrong
okay yeah so one other thing that you
want to mention and here is for instance
polygons inside of geometric scene
includes the assertion that it's a
simple polygon oh why don't we say that
it's a simple polygon and also so I
think line segment so outside of
geometric scene line segments of your
line gives a multi-line inside of
geometric scene it's a straight line
sure that's explicit in line segment but
I think it's a straight line
how many how many points can it have any
number I think alphabetical order is the
correct thing why for example look at
graphics no that's a different thing I
mean this has much more structure I
think oh maybe it doesn't I don't know
all right okay fair enough
okay straight line okay so then we've
got then here we've got some regular
polygons what is that form there's a lot
of optional arguments basic form was
just in yeah and first and then but it's
got to give some points doesn't it all
right um excluded it cuz it doesn't
really fit in very well with everything
else well why not cuz it's gonna put it
at a particular coordinates like how do
you establish how do you assess how do
you say that something is a regular
polygon geometric assertion okay okay
let's loop back to this just say just
saying um okay the hypotheses in a scene
um when an object is given in the
hypothesis
is foreseen it
No when an object appears as a
hypothesis and a scene it assumes no
yeah and this temperature saying but I
think it's just utterly obscure it's a
hack I mean it was is a in a scene can
assert that certain objects exist as
well as give relations and other
assertions about those objects the
following primitives can be used to
indicate the particular objects exist in
a scene okay and now we need to say the
points the the points PTI that as well
as the parameters as well as parameters
such as are the points PTI and parameter
um can be okay so we don't even say here
that the peep that they can be okay okay
let's say this in geometric scene of P 1
P 2 dot dot the piece of I can be
symbols or any other type of expression
the most common bug would be pork these
things can be strings symbols or any
strings symbols or any other type of
expression it's of course not on ups
then call it what do you mean it cannot
be two two is the expression okay me
strings symbols or mean on system
expression or other symbolic expressions
yeah um functions such as random
instance fill in specific values for the
P sub I um satisfying and case of us um
in such a way as to satisfy in such a
way as to satisfy the hypotheses Allie
and our live stream is asking can you
fit a circle through and real points
using circle through and find its radius
what's the answer we dropped the radius
function but implicitly you can use
ready you cannot give a symbolic Center
and a symbolic radius is optional second
and third arguments on the malt are we
inside or outside of geometric scene
well let's say outside
this is Charles's territory then
so this is the thing and then what do we
do here we want to find out so good it
would evaluate to circle of center comma
radius I mean if you'll open the
documentation it sees discolor
what should I do wrong what are you
wrong here I didn't yet committed the
code so you come back on you I get it
okay but this will turn into so this
will do exactly what Ali wants it to do
yes oh it's off equivalent to C Conn's
here give you exactly that if you apply
right now you can see on it what's on my
nose the head okay that's super cool how
do you mean - the head why - the head
well sir I'm going to attend a circle
using sweetie
Yeah right oh I see I see I see I see I
see I see this one should return circle
rather than it should simplify that the
head yes okay yeah now what happens if I
give it a point that doesn't that
doesn't lie on that circle should be a
list of three finally independent points
come now we've fixed that okay very good
okay new fixes the message I'm gonna fix
this mathematics
you
in such ways okay fern specific cows in
such a way I don't think it wants the
comma there okay hypotheses are seen can
assert to certain objects exist
okay why don't we just say why don't we
put it the other way around it can give
relations and assertions about objects
in the scene
well actually can give
actually no um okay wilmut can list
objects that must appear in the scene
and can give relations and assertions
about those objects how about that that
looks like that's so much better it's
not even funny
okay good the UM phone to to indicate
the particular objects but we actually
use the same words appear in a scene
existing a scene appear we can say
exists I don't think it hurts anything
there okay the points PTI I mean but not
every time that you're using those
primitives are you gonna be using it to
a certain thing exist you might be using
it inside an assertion or inside or I
see you're just using animate I see I
see um okay the following primitives to
be indicate to objects-- in a scene
can be used the following primitives can
be used to represent a metric objects to
represent geometric objects a problem
with that okay it's Aryan do you have
like regular polygon rectangle and
parallelogram listed elsewhere I know so
I said that again what the regular
polygon parallelogram and rectangle
should be supported but are I think
currently undocumented also put them in
I mean uh oh you mean this is what an
earlier is they they those things take
stuff like vectors and put things in
particular areas
well rectally so that exists um so yeah
that's actually a question I currently
support say rectangle of the list of
points which doesn't match any
documented that's no good okay so I mean
listen listen for Charles's purposes I
don't even know what Charles does for uh
in parallelogram but I mean you know
parallelogram could have two lives one
that's based on explicit coordinate
lists that has one form that uses vector
the vector representation I'm this is a
bit horrifying and the other that's
based on points okay yeah is that
plausible or is that hopeless it's
always two arguments talks is fifty
different there shouldn't be a problem
my local version of I don't personally
see much value in it
considering the way of geometric
assertion you can assert that something
too parallelogram where do we stop with
this do we also add trapezoid compass
yeah why not I mean because because that
way you can say I mean in the in the
statement of a geometric you know and
make
geometric statement you will have and
the rhombus ABCD blah blah blah and I
don't see why we shouldn't have that and
I think it's consistent with this to
have parallelogram I mean right now you
have parallelogram oh but but but right
now we have a situation where generic
values represent existing objects if we
have this all determined things form the
name and behave still the same number of
arguments generically they don't exist
anymore if you've got a polygon a
triangle let's say with ABC so what I'm
imagining is that it's parallelogram
ABCD but then for generic utilizations
of ABCD this object doesn't exist right
points for my body good point good point
I understand that all right but all of
these have the property but it's not a
matter of how you're going to use it
right the same house polygon right you
give point p1 p2 p3 you assume that
samples right so you see my playful pile
Elohim he does that we you know we have
a specific syntax that P comma the
vector I mean there's no issue of
extending it typically we don't use
argument structures where some arguments
can be derived from the rest why but for
us is more of a matter of detecting that
is a valid has noise not evaluation we
don't do anything with that and in
German our to interpret it but but
Michaels point is that the four argument
parallelogram the fourth this point here
doesn't even need to be stated is the
same has a circle to right well
essentially you need to have extra
points if you give extra points yes go
through so if the point is not valid
we'll come back on the back okay fair
enough
fair enough so what your point is that
parallelogram could work with three
points I don't know which three points I
guess the one 1/4 and the two data
percentage corresponding vectors
I see so then so then the former's so
then the alternative form is
parallelogram of list PT 1 2 3 , dot dot
well
the dot dot is only it can only have one
more so then we probably want to do the
same thing with regular polygon right we
could have a regular polygon form
plunges go ahead would this be a
primitive what do you mean by that would
there be evaluation of it because this
is a big difference between circle
through circle through evaluates to a
circle this parallelogram just stays
parallelogram doesn't really matter for
you know when you have studied your
matrix in weight was some primitive we
just take that they're valid and flag
them so consider has a spinet evaluate
or not it doesn't change much I think
it's nice to have this capability to
have parallelogram to be able to say you
know cuz you know you're translating I
mean we haven't really okay here's a
question guys how much of Euclid have we
been able to translate how much we could
have we bothered to translate so far
into the stuff we've never tried to just
translate Euclid I think we should get
somebody to do that I think it'd be a
great project for some student e-type I
mean some you know even high school
student who's studying geometry you know
it would be a great project to try and
just translate Euclid you know jump
2,000 years a little bit more than that
for Euclid and translate it into this
form I mean should work right every
every proposition in you played well at
least all the geometric ones should be
translated
correct the 2d ones yeah
yeah okay so if I pick a random one if I
pick a Euclid I think I even have a copy
of Euclid on my shelf here let's say oh
yeah so I do so I do um alright I'm
gonna pick a random page oh boy this is
in Greek scheme otter youth the graphic
grammar s Teeter Hooper I think I might
even be able to translate this hmm Wow
all that education might be useful well
I can more let's get that okay but
anyway it says some uh uh oh these are a
bunch of definitions wait wait wait that
that was a bunch of notes and that was
silly this is this is this book is full
of notes okay here we go here's the
actual propositions boy he has the
geometric solution of a quadratic
equation I didn't know you had that um
okay this is probably not a good use of
our time um I don't even know
I don't think Euclid had his I mean I'm
pretty sure the original Euclid
documents at least as they've survived
don't have the proofs but anyway all
right so
oh boy these are complicated proposition
to cut a given straight line so that the
rectangle contained by the hole and one
of the segments is equal to the square
on the remaining segment I don't
understand that I mean that means that's
that's that's a construction right right
now how do we do something like that
what does it even mean to do that we're
not really representing constructions
right now what would we need to do in
order to represent constructions no but
I understand that why isn't it the same
thing because we're gonna have a random
instance again I mean I think in citing
about compass and straightedge
constructions well in the stomach I
think this is a construction like that
as well and just I'm not sure um becomes
easier for you our compasses straight
edges and computers to this discussion
we had about option saying that some
points are free that we have to go
strictly forward like we cannot andum Li
have non-local points a construction is
an ordered sequence of steps where at
each step you introduce a new point that
wasn't previous in any of the present so
in other words what you're saying is to
a geometric scene there should be an
operation you can perform that basically
says you know stick the compass you know
twirl the compass around and put it down
at this place or something well in order
to be able to do Euclid stuff ya know to
do a construction right is to represent
but then
I see but then we have to represent a
series of steps in the construction huh
it would be kind of two steps first it
would be similar like you get elects old
also critical paces so then each new
equation has only one variable more an
addition you would need a connector
between each two lines okay but so I'm
just trying to check that our
representation here isn't going to fall
a plot if we have to deal with
constructions we definitely be extended
yeah but is it going to is it gonna fail
I mean how do what is the relationship
between geometric scene and what you
need for a construction geometric scene
is the last the very end of the
construction I see so you're claiming
that the assertions what are you
claiming you claiming that there are
assertions or there must be assertion
you defied the assertion you refight the
assertion in such a way that miss each
new assertion you only use things you
had earlier okay okay but so look I mean
you know they're things like given a
regular pentagon you know pick you know
put your compass on one of the points of
the Pentagon draw a circle that goes
around another you know points in the
Pentagon and then put a line between
this and that I think a construction
would probably be a sequence of
geometric scenes and you said you have a
geometric scene and then you would have
a process that would tell you how to get
from one to the next one where the
geometric scenes but then you have to
how would that work with variable
scoping because what you're saying is
you'd start off with a symbolic set of
things and then you would be adding at
each step you would add essentially a
somewhat arbitrary but with an assertion
yeah I mean like if you say with a
compass
do this it would say you know there's a
the distance between that and that is
equal to this if we probably still have
say a geometric seen hat but also having
in the second argument right now list or
something like this we could have an
association which is the number the
steps and we wouldn't have a popular
Vista variable names yeah I understand
so what would that look like Michael I
mean we so we'd say geometric scene and
then we'd start saying Association step
one then what I was able seeing like the
salt of step ones is seen one other sort
of step two is seen two ice hmm okay
interesting I mean it's not completely
obvious to me because that's not
describing the construction that's
merely describing the results of the
construction all right boy it's
disappointing that after 20 how long is
it 2200 years of something that we still
can't completely nail you know a
computable version of Euclid another
site like if you think only mr. recent
function of adding something to both
sides to equation we can do some simple
refighting of an equation for
somatically even this is only very new
well I understand that I understand that
I mean so what's your point that that's
new or that that's I mean to what extent
is that like the stuff that you would do
in the Euclidian case and in the
Euclid's construction type case it would
take something that you have a equally B
plus two and you do something to it to
get something new right but so basically
what you're saying is you take it to
your metric scene and you do something
to it to get a new one right fair enough
okay all right let's keep going here
okay the points P sub I um can be
symbolic the points and parameters in
geometric objects the points in and
parameters can have can be symbolic or
can have and parameters can be symbolic
or can have explicit values are you
rewriting your second line from above no
I'm writing about this ah can be
symbolic or can have explicit values
correct
it come here it could be a circle of
radius one or something yeah okay okay
next okay okay now you've told me these
are constructions by done entirely by
that now there are the results of
constructions yeah let's just pick up
all the stuff here
the term construction is overloaded in
mathematics okay but if you think they
should NiCd pointed there are various
points that go in and you get didn't you
object out okay
okay the following
used the following constructions
on geometric parameter on geometric
objects
structions the following can be used to
represent
structions applied geometric objects
is that reasonable or do you want to
actually mention on the right-hand side
what sort of primitive it actually is
like angle bisector is a infinite line
yes angle bisector as an infinite line
midpoint that's the point it's really
obvious perpendicular bisector as a what
infinite region centroid as a point
region point nearest to region is that
right
point no it isn't it points in a region
nearest area right point nearest point
in a region what is triangle construct
it's terrible Wow okay
okay okay the following assertions about
geometric objects and their properties
can be given um this should say a point
is in a region um
I think here we should just say values
are numerically equal it might not be
numbers designed to value right what is
what does it mean with equal well say
you can say but t equals equals triangle
of ABC and oldest represent the triangle
anywhere in the same I see a facility
for today just to just say point is in a
region equality assertion
geometric object is that correct
assertion or relation and it could be
more than one object is it a name
decision yeah yeah okay what's this
that's the same as the element at the
top so I'm also supporting less than
greater than yeah mother that will need
to be fixed that that was that's that's
stylistically wrong that thing we read
remember at the top that make sense and
we use less than and qualitative values
or objects yes absolutely less than
greater than work don't they I'm not so
sure it's fish of implementation can you
use inequalities in a geometric scene
yeah and use in equations as in not
equal to now because fine minimum can't
handle those okay okay well there are
ways if you explicitly say points are
distinct kind of like that inside of
geometric assertion I forget what the
string argument is then it will handle
it but if you just have a not a general
not equals it it'll return on evaluated
I think then you wanted to mention the
subset of your right so inequalities
and equality is between values yeah yeah
that's formatting is not correct there
so for the top one we also support lists
of points as subsets of regions if
you're using the I wanna upset set a
nerd subset or subset equal okay just in
sight
so you're saying here if I say I can say
a list of points here right and then
what a subset so no element sign
yes up set subset okay a set of points
are in a region right subsidy equals
works too but it of course just to make
sure that Sybil is hope in the sense of
this cannot really relate because we
probably two and would you use subset
for this oh isn't there a subset queue
this isn't subset Q is it now it's bonus
trust to use the symbol because it's
nice right
but there's meaning attached to the
symbol but there isn't a meaning as the
in Mathematica there's not we are
attaching by putting in a geometric say
it's the point well that's a big deal I
mean that means that is it subset Cure's
it's something else
let's not document this right now this
is something we need to figure out it by
it was mentioning it right
yeah we can't really use subsets q
though because I know it will evaluate
yeah in some weird way right well to
false
okay the following assertions about
geometric objects and the focus can be
used the following measurements on
geometric objects okay okay okay um okay
now we have to say
okay under the third line functions such
as random instance we need to have a
similar thing for functions such as fine
geometric conjectures fill-in
conclusions the reason why we're saying
functions functions in the plural when
you know there's only these two specific
functions I don't think this one should
go in here I think this should go
further down we're still trying to okay
so next thing we have to say is this
thing about the multiple cases I think
you know what I have off a mind to say
geometric scene
gives properties gives properties very
much
the property gives I think these are
always strings right okay list of
conclusions about the scene well those
two conclusions it may not be ml the
scene there is a graphics object okay
there diagram as a graphics object
diagram of the scene do the same thing
for tab view yeah okay list of instances
of the scene
list two points
well now what does it do if they have
okay list appoints list appoint
specifications for the scene list of
scalar value specifications sounds
reasonable
okay
diagram office as a tap the object
what's that say that again diagram of
the scene comma as a tab view object no
yeah what's up I said it should be
diagrams because tab you tabbed dabbled
tabbed collection of diagrams of seen
instances that may not be the only kind
of tab view if there's if there's
conjectures you also get a tab view that
highlights the conjectures right but the
tab view sub value I think only works on
when we're considering multiple
geometric scenes and I think that's
wrong and okay so what do you think it
should do we can get a tab view for two
different things having more than one
seen instance or for having conjectures
they need to be highlighted I'm not sure
that's right I'm not sure that's the
right way to do it I'm not sure that
that second thing should should be the
same as tabbing through seen instances
really don't think that should be
necessarily the same and how do you
visually tell the difference between a
scene with conclusions
one that doesn't I don't know what to
see yeah tab for the it looks like a tab
deal
yeah but the for the conclusion each tab
is a list each tab is is the conclusion
you know the name of the tab is the
particular conclusion for the for the
distal geometric scene instance each tab
name of the tab is just successive
integer but we could have various
versions of the tape view stream you
know they may feel you be tipping slow
yeah I think so I agree I don't think
this is right so I'm gonna I'm gonna
future eyes this for right now and let's
figure out a proposal for that let's
just try keep getting through these and
I'm I'm worried that I'm gonna run out
of time here um okay the very beginning
point do we want to spell out that it
doesn't have any hold on tribute does it
fully evaluate its second and first
argument oh really wanted to give it
because that seemingly from what I
understand form of a safe from deep
meeting devout discussion about this let
me avoid that point right now okay
because I think if it doesn't hold its
arguments we can be silent on the matter
okay okay
okay so in the form geometric scene of
scene one scene to scene three I don't
even understand what that scene one
scene
- I will actually evaluate to a
geometric scene where it collects
together the okay values in the first
argument okay that automatically format
isn't AB view it's converted to a
geometric scene object in which each
point or scalar value in which MA
Paul and which a list of forms lista
forms as given for each point or scalar
value is that right no looks like it's
right it looks here like it's right it's
not in which um in which multiple lists
of points and scalar values is given the
resulting construct do we want to put
devote expertise number here so the W
gets confused to receive multiple okay
fine okay with with explicit explicit
seen seen eyes
explicit seen instances seen I do want
to say of the same abstract same here
yeah well um let's say that as a
separate sentence it's converted to a
single it's correct and which multiple
lists appoints and scalar values are
given the scene I well the resulting
same objects yeah yeah I understand is
converted to it in which so okay it's
converted to a object too much multiple
the servos given so long as the scene I
as long as all the scene I correspond to
the same abstract scene
you want to say correspond or are
instances of are instances of okay mats
as a tab here I'm going to say that next
thing um
geometric seen when geometric scene
represents multiple instances of a scene
it is normally displayed in tabbed form
as a tab you object okay and should that
be moved up to the topic so no I
absolutely don't think so I think it's
super confusing okay what's this down
here I know not all possible sugar dogs
okay okay the display of constructs of
geometric objects can be
specified using style style information
style specifications do not affect to
affect the geometric meaning is that
right correct okay whoops that was wrong
press the wrong button is it normal to
say for geometric scene when you're
talking about the options it is well
you'd have this long and ponderous or
discussion oh my god what a mess why
isn't that an association this is
patterned off of method sub-options I
think it should be an association just
frequently all right okay well because
we didn't have associations when we
first started that's that's though it's
yes can be provided
should be the standard wording well I
hate it any option of graphics can be
given functions
geometric injections fill-in conclusions
in geometric scene objects okay um okay
a bit about conjectures be up higher no
no it should not because this is
confusing enough as it is right if you
know it's like you can't say everything
first see what I'm saying
gotta make a decision what we say first
and I think you know what we say last
has some punch as well so we go make a
choice okay this is surely not the only
stuff that we should refer to from
geometric scene here surely geometric
assertion belongs here among other
things yeah definitely geometric
assertion I would have thought graphics
should be here as well anything else
maybe tab you probably not though no no
definitely not
now I wonder whether we should point
things like circle to geometric scene I
I do currently are you in it so you've
put that in in circle yeah yes for that
last time okay fine
there's a wine at the bottom of the
details that says circle can be used
with symbolic points and quantities and
then okay great and it points it down
here right yep magnificent that's great
that's exactly what we want okay that
was a bit more time-consuming than I
expected so we've now got these other
ones fine geometric conjectures and that
we do random instance let's look at
random instance again
well it is what it is there I think
that's yeah okay okay I don't think
that's terrible
okay let's go well let's see should we
look at your metric assertion is that
gonna be easier I don't think any of
these are gonna be easy
no lovely magnificent
represents the assertion that all the
objects fight proper right
no because prop might be a relation
between the alibi
why is that giving a spellcheck error
there you know I've seen these lingering
spell checks a bunch recently I think
there's a 64-bit fund and one of the
bits got left over ok kickin and Andrea
can you report that please yes I just I
mean I don't think it's a little hard to
reproduce but I think they need to
figure out you know yeah no he doesn't
reproduce is just yeah I just took a
screenshot and I'm going to send it I
think it goes away after birth well okay
they need to go home for this I have to
say the 64-bit front end has been I I've
forgotten that it was 64-bit it's
surprisingly stable
you
okay all right
okay
what do you mean points Oh regions
kinds of stuff
those are the two kinds of things that
can be good with other things are there
well can be points or regions specified
I mean they can be you know
perpendicular bisector of a list of a
that is a perpendicular bisector really
a region I don't think so it's an
infinite line you know that but it's
very confusing to people because they'll
think region means a region object um I
don't think we should put this in here I
think this is not relevant I think we
don't need that line I think that line
only confuses things
you
you
just put this down at the bottom
you
okay points form of putter clockwise
polygon is that fair you know you use
that on a polygon okay you can actually
use that same string on either a polygon
or on a list of points which is why it's
also under relations as well as
predicates okay a polygon has the points
and a polygon our clockwise go and
clockwise Organa a polygon is convex do
you mean two vertex point not the point
in a polygon yeah the vertices of a
polygon
okay what is this one
oh my god this cichlid what's that what
does that mean the vertices are lie in a
circle oh wow I never would have figured
that out the vertices polygons lie on a
circle okay what angle Sinope oh sorry
what's wrong with a polygon is cyclic
well I didn't know what that meant
yeah well if you don't know what convex
means you won't know what a polygon is
convex means yeah but people know that
I'm using myself as a test I don't know
what a cyclic polygon high school
geometry students can be more likely to
know cyclic than convex okay but people
know the word convex is a piece of
everyday you know well they are that if
they don't know what it you know
defining convex is more complicated the
angles in a polygon are equal vertex
angles or interior angles are all equal
the side lengths in a polygon are all
equal and say all right polygons yeah
okay a polygon is for angular and my
equilateral is regular let's just say
it's regular I don't even know probably
gonna simple what does that mean it
decides our non self intersecting so we
already inside of geometric seen when
you just sees polygon without this it
already assumes that it's simple so not
sure we should list it here okay let's
future is it him okay polygons for
polygons or lists of points now these
are none of these are for lists or
points okay following predicate for
polygons can be used right um you know
we don't even then need to say I will
polygon the vertices are in clockwise
order the polygon is convex the vertices
are in counterclockwise order the
vertices lie on a circle interior angles
are all equal like this you're missing a
space on that granular to the right
angles are there here okay
between points can be used okay what
does this mean in the place in clockwise
order well so it means that the if you
relative to the original what now if you
draw line segments between neighboring
points it forms the boundary of a simple
polygon whose vertices are in clockwise
order hmm points are in clockwise order
if joined that's a pretty obscure one
okay points lie on a line must be the
points yep also for the one above
okay does this mean that they lie on a
circle this means now this means that
they're either clockwise or
counterclockwise I see well the points
don't double back so it means well it
well they don't necessarily have to
double back for this to be a twofer to
not be so quickly ordered yeah I think
what are you doing this right yeah
what's this one you form successive
angles between the pairs of points with
the vertex at Pt okay and then all those
angles are equal okay successive angles
at the vertex PT or something like that
it's used for like trisected and insect
'uncle x' like if you want to say that I
understand I understand well how about
this subtended at PTR equal that right
okay okay this has been been future eyes
down to parallel have I like that
because the most recent time I looked
anti parallel wasn't working but except
okay I yeah I think yeah I have it fixed
okay so between lines and other regions
I mean these are mostly okay what if
what are similar lines mean what would
that even mean so all lines are all
finite lines are similar lines of the
same length they're congruent I see
between lines and other regions can be
used well that makes it seem like one of
the one of the parts of the relations
has to be aligned okay but you can't say
regions here most people aren't gonna
get
goodnight scum a circus okay lines
circles okay okay okay so what does
parallel mean if you said about
triangles has no minute okay so maybe we
should break this table into ones that
are about lines and ones that are about
more general things okay
some will be in multiple than that which
ones will be a multiple well so it could
work for anything what's that say it
again congruent I don't care that we can
say it about about figures because the
fact that there's a special case that
congruent works for lines is amusing but
not too relevant is it or do people
right now it's you you're welcome grant
circles if you send times concurrent
circles is fine if we would say okay
following relations between lines can be
used right the following relations
between following relations
between other between geometric objects
can be used which by the way actually
says the right thing now because right
because it's it's actually um somebody
is making very funky noises there okay
lines are anti-parallel well just anti
parallel line lines are anti parallel
lines are lines what's that
otherwise I would say parallel and in
opposite direction said okay but in
opposite directions lines are concurrent
or on top of each other well no no they
they meet and they meet in a common
point oh well yeah so I didn't know what
I was talking about lines weren't used
the word intersect okay
lines intersect at a call we got
feedback from a WTC attendee that they
had trouble finding that well maybe it's
the wrong name concurrent concurrence
well we can't stand intellect
terminology okay okay
lines intersect at the point PT is that
right correct yep okay we've got
something that sounds distinctly like
you know ocean um
background noise okay congruent doesn't
go here right correct
matching parallel what does that mean
why they're parallel in the same
direction
what the heck just
that mean then to just parallel with no
reference to the direction that standard
usage for in Crowell and antiparallel
yes we introduced matching parallel
because there's no pre-existing term the
convention is people use parallel to
mean matching parallel in it just in
cases where they care about that right a
lot of times they say parallel and
they're leaving out a hypothesis
Oh parallel with with any direction with
any orientation yeah relative that with
any relative orientation okay pairwise
tangent that's all yeah liens lines are
perpendicular mutually tangent doesn't
go here right no that's I think all of
these should be the lines to be
symmetric yes all right okay you can
fill in the rest I'll do that
okay okay
okay pairwise tangent what does that
mean that means that each each pair of
objects is tangent to each other but it
could be at different points for
different pairs the objects are tangent
to each other in pairs yes okay
what is mutually tangent mean they're
all tangent at the same point are all
tangent at a point okay okay aren't
there a lot of other assertions here
aren't a lot of other Q functions that
we want to say that are here I mean
region member what's that we we do
support region member but we could add a
bunch of Q functions but never do that
they're not I'm not suggesting they're
supported in geometric scene
the claim here is how do you tell so if
I say geometric assertion
oh all right it only works inside of
geometric same oh I think what you're
looking for will be fine geometric proof
in the next version whatever I just
won't find if it's true
I mean I might want to find out if if if
it's true but concrete objects because
we didn't want to do this this was part
why we introduced this genetic assertion
which more emphasizes this dating I
understand that I understand it but we
might want to another function that just
does it I think if there's another
function that does it we might just keep
I mean I'm mature we need another fun
another function I think the idea was
yeah if it's concrete it will just do it
yeah I think we should make that happen
I think it's for you as Charles - with
us yeah okay we would like this to
actually evaluate all the possible
predicates I mean we have convex
polygons it's a matter of design how now
which direction we're going if you want
to genetic accession to evaluate for
concrete which on key object like that
we can work on it let's depend how far
we want to go on the current design I'm
sorry I spaced for a second
so 20 we introduced like they convex
polygon Q does those checking so do we
want also to support German I mean to
implement genetic accession for all
these predicates do we want to support
you know symbolic parameter is that
whole build up need to discuss
separately if you want that I don't know
whether we want some
parameters that seems complicated I mean
the the I think ultimately we might want
that but I mean these are just look
these things sorry you have a convex
polygon Q is that correct yes oh boy so
if I say convex polygon interesting so
if I put an A in here why does it say
that I'm sorry you can't make on okay to
a B but well in principle it should give
false that's about because you you know
do a con overlapping you should be on
the cost you know constant which you
should always give false so John is not
constant okay but this doesn't give
symbolic I mean the the it will be super
interesting to me all right so I agree
that geometric assertion would be
magnificent if it gave you no symbolic
if it translated this to a symbolic form
I guess okay so listen this should
certainly refer to things like convex
polygon Q what else should it refer to
of that type do we have a similar q
charles or congruent no we just have
convex 40 count you okay what about what
about things being on other place things
simple simple simple
yeah right so I don't think we should do
that I think we should say well we could
have it at the end
I mean checking that a point is on a
line is like reduce or something isn't
it remember okay okay
should we have regular polygons no
because it's a constructor not a cure
all right now we've got this thinking
this is way too many examples of the
same thing I mean wait a minute what was
that their motions oh you you haven't
even got basic examples you need to add
basic examples here we'll get two
examples okay
all right so now up here now we're gonna
go ah sigh triangle Center I'm hoping
this is fairly straightforward he says
famous last words
and to the center of the specified
height of the triangle try Arbor for
either one that's useful them following
center types can be used we give them I
think we went through this before I know
we haven't because you've never been
able to update it right we went through
some of triangle construct and this is
basically a subset of triangle sub
construct okay let me look them thank
you for out there sum of triangle
construct maybe not no I don't think so
oh boy okay and the other thing we've
got my gosh let's just look at triangle
measurement okay and then we've got fine
geometric conjectures oh who said this
was gonna be like super simple and short
I think I may have said that
sarcastically once okay fine um let's
look at this before we go back I mean
the triangle Center stuff is gonna be
straightforward I think if
time-consuming let's take a look at this
so it doesn't actually find those
conjectures it reinsert them into the
scene right correct oh boy how to say
that just put it in the details all
right but if I say this so if I take
this guy here I won't find any for just
a triangle didn't have a triangle it was
forced to have an angle of something
okay hey I hear hear how I'm gonna put
something in here I'm gonna say planar
angle see if I know what I'm doing
planar angle of ABC equals equals PI
over 2 magnificent find geometric okay I
don't even understand what it would have
done okay so let's put let's put a thing
here and let's see may have done
something yeah put a circle yeah yeah I
need it should return that the other
angles are 45 degrees no I wouldn't
because that's not necessarily true
nevermind you would okay so what the
heck am I doing here
how does it it should have some
indicator saying earlier this should be
a tab view that correct merged yet yeah
and locally this would be a tab view can
you show that to me you want me to share
my screen yeah she can oh you can just
send me a notebook that has it in let me
share my screen probably so you don't
have to load maybe she
a message will be doing funding right
definitely
your you'd have to stop sharing your
screen no very good
let's see what I'm looking for uh let's
go with unfortunately I will have to
leave okay Charles well you can always
watch the the archive of this there we
go pleasure and hopefully somebody will
take notes if you need to be aware of
things okay see let's see yeah there we
go
so that's with style let's see and down
here find geometric conjectures no I
don't want to see the input form get rid
of the input form I'm not just in the
input for and right so the more many of
this get rid of the full matching
because otherwise the for hunting is
gonna confuse us
yeah oh this okay that's just kind of
just looking at this fine geometric
conjectures of sales pick one so I
understand but so many sales pick one
sure what else but one is okay so that's
what I was saying get rid of the red it
moves to hit this what Stevens oh I
sorry i sorry um yeah
yeah I get rid of that import I don't
understand the import form they can you
say that what are you doing if you want
to know what I see you're doing the
crazy thing putting multiple stuff on a
single input line right state that this
is primetime viewing Oh
equals oh that's no no that's a
parentheses should be a no okay
is that okay okay fine okay now say find
on that alright go back up the is it say
find geometric conjectures right I don't
understand this okay so it is using some
color that it picks out of somewhere
right so it's highlighting the
conjecture so here it's saying these two
lines are perpendicular so these two
lines get highlighted you say that this
angle is 90 degrees which is equivalent
it shows but but does it okay all right
okay way too much okay so listen listen
um let's talk about the graphic design
of this um I mean like planar angle ABC
obviously there's a traditional form
there that has an angle thing could
could whoever's making the background
there's a there okay okay so this is
some weird tab view with a side tab okay
and what's happened there so that the
thing I'm trying to understand how
complicated to these get what happens if
those things get really complicated -
conjectures
two conjectures maybe make them we know
them so head no at least be doing search
for wondered over to the right so Len
had the had the option that I currently
don't have activated of some sort of
plaintext to the side that would
hopefully cut down on the size but it's
a little weird and I don't think we
should divorce the method option where
we can specify the type view option in
case we want it that's true okay I'm in
this thing okay so what happens if I
just want the plain Jane diagram without
the conjectures I can't get it in the
after after I found the geometric
conjectures presumably there's a thing
here which will get me back the
uncongested form what's the property
that just gets me back the original
instance without the conjectures well I
think we have one currently it would be
trivial to end do edit new string
version that just leads it off yeah yeah
we should do that alright
what would should we call it cannot be
chose no no I understand that but I'm
just saying something like scene might
be the male you're saying conjecture it
should be conclusion that conjecture we
have formally always refer to them as
conclusions that conjectures they may
need active few Dibby you might want the
one that basic is totally cleaned off
what we called earlier the up stock
scene and we want the instance
yes yes this that's a good one abstract
scene and then scene instance we have
instances already right right we have
instances Batsford multiple this means
something else
so it's an abstract scene and it is a
scene instance or this thing so yeah I
would think scene instance is the right
thing okay how is scene instance
different instances well and scene
instant strips away the strips away the
conjecture it's not totally obvious from
the name yeah it's not yeah I don't
think it's quite right I think we just
need one more for abstract scene where
do you mean one Oh
just I only see the need for one more
sub option or sub value so you're saying
instances [ __ ] already that's what we're
saying yeah but it gets just the
instances but but see look there's two
different things there are multiple
instance it's not um a practical point
are we going to continue for a while
or we should we wrap up and continue at
a different time I love to wrap up I
think could you give me back my screen
here sir so we're gonna have to continue
this probably if we can um two more I
think we should try for my tomorrow is
really busy well let's see what can be
done for tomorrow um
yeah I think we Michael when when are
you taking off I am still available
tomorrow and Monday's okay okay um I'm a
little concerned here okay so I'm not
too concerned about the triangle centers
I love - can I have anything terribly
horrifying there um
this
find geometric conjectures looks a bit
iffy to me I mean you're saying I mean
it is that it is the main event here so
you know that's some um okay
all right let's try to continue even if
briefly tomorrow um and okay I'm gonna
push all these results back into the
repository great okay beautiful
functionality talk to y'all soon
Thanks okay see ya bye